bonsoir à toutes et bonsoir à tous je
suis ravi et flatté d'être devant vous
ce soir
un patient est aussi intimidée à l'idée
de parler d'un sujet que je n'ai pas
vraiment l'habitude d'aborder pour tout
vous dire
c'est une première pour moi ce soir à la
fois sur le fond et sur la forme
une façon vous me direz de repousser mes
limites et ça tombe bien puisque c'est
un peu le thème de cette soirée
alors contrairement aux autres
intervenants je ne suis spécialiste
d'aucune discipline
je ne suis ni physiciens et chimistes et
biologistes
je ne suis pas enseignante en fait je ne
suis qu'un passeur mon rôle consiste à
faire le lien entre les sachants et ceux
qui se nourrissent de leur savoir si
j'ai accepté cette tribune c'est parce
que j'estime que depuis que je mène
cette activité je n'ai jamais cessé de
repousser mes limites limites
intellectuelles physiques et
psychologiques également si je ne devais
en citer qu'une je vous parlerai en
priorité de cette limite franchie il y à
23 ans
sans ce geste je pense que je ne serai
pas là ce soir il ya 23 ans je suis
journaliste
mon rédacteur en chef s'appelle frédéric
courant mon camarade fresnes
ni lui ni moi ne sommes scientifique et
pourtant nous allons créer ensemble
l'émission c'est pas sorcier
le magazine de la découverte et de la
science alors certains parmi vous se
souviennent certainement du générique
ce camion américain au pot d'échappement
rutilant s'élançant sur une petite route
du massif central et piloté par un
certain merci ça lui fera plaisir
alors ce n'était pas la première limite
que je franchissais adolescent je rêvais
de devenir reporter en quittant l'école
de journalisme
mon truc c'est la radio et la presse
écrite
j'aime ces médias parce que j'aime
raconter j'aime les mots j'aime la
richesse de la langue française
l'étendue de son vocabulaire les mots
qui permettent quand on aime témoigner
de décrire avec justesse et précision
ces mots aussi qui permettent de créer
dans la tête de l'auditeur du lecteur
des ambiances des images est d'ailleurs
toujours pensé que les mots sont les
premiers outils à partir desquels des
hommes ont fabriqué des images
virtuelles cérébrale mais bien virtuel
toujours est il que je me retrouve
parachuté à radio france d'abord à lille
puis à bordeaux
nous sommes en 1989 au mois d'octobre
j'ai quelques contacts
à berlin en 1989 l'europe est divisée en
deux par ce que l'on appelle le rideau
de fer
un coup de téléphone et je comprends
qu'il est en train de se passer quelque
chose d'important quelque chose
d'historique
alors je voulais dit à cette époque je
n'ai pas d'affinités avec la télévision
mais je comprends qu'il ne suffit pas de
raconter qu'il faut aussi montrer
repousser ses limites c'est aussi aller
contre ses convictions se remettre en
question on prête une caméra et me voilà
à berlin je filme la chute du mur les
berlinois n'est pas ceux de l'est qui se
ruent vers l'ouest des berlinois de
l'ouest des étudiants en médecine qui
vont chercher un job à l'est
j'ai compris ce jour là qu'on pouvait
raconter des histoires aussi forte avec
les images qu avec les mots et que
peut-être en mariant les deux ça
pourrait être encore plus fort nous
revoici en 1994 alors au début des
années 90 la science et la télévision
c'est une affaire sérieuse
quand je dis ça je dis rien à la
télévision on ne plaisante pas avec la
science sur le fond c'est très bien sur
la forme c'est un peu ennuyeux
en général les scientifiques qui
s'expriment devant une caméra utilise un
langage d'experts toujours facile à
comprendre pas toujours accessibles et
puis sur la forme les émissions
s'organise plutôt autour de sujets dans
lesquels on trouve on découvre une
innovation innovation qui est ensuite
commenté en plateau par d'autres
scientifiques le plus ennuyeux dans tout
cela en fait c'est que le public
n'adhère plus à ce genre d'émission
et le fossé se creuse de plus
en plus entre la science et la société
française alors c'est vrai que lorsque
nous sommes arrivés avec notre camion et
notre ferme résolution de vouloir rendre
la science accessible à tous et même aux
enfants et bien nous avons un peu
repoussé les limites du genre
la suite vous la connaissez 19 ans 570
émission 570 sujets pour lesquels et là
je ne parle qu'à titre personnel j'ai dû
repousser les limites de mes
connaissances en effet je suis incapable
de parler d'un sujet sans en maîtriser
les bases
or vous savez je voulais dit je ne suis
pas scientifique
je me souviens de la première émission
une émission consacrée aux sons elle
avait été tourné à la rochelle aux
francofolies j'avais moi même choisi ce
thème peut-être parce que je ne
connaissais pas grand chose à ce
phénomène esprit de curiosité et bien
c'est comme si j'étais retourné à
l'école je me souviens redécouvrant le
phénomène physique conceptualisant long
de mécanique la vibration des molécules
qui composent l'air jusqu'au teintant
des notions que j'estimais essentiel des
notions qui devaient être transmises au
public si on voulait aller plus loin par
les d'acoustique alors au cours de cette
émission j'ai rappelé la composition de
l'air j'ai fait un peu d'anatomie le
tympan le fonctionnement de l'oreille
interne un peu de technologie aussi le
micro avec l'électro et man puis il ya
eu une émission sur les paquebots sur la
ferme les tours l'homme de cro magnon
les sous marins les fourmis les
centrales nucléaires
pour toutes ces émissions j'ai dû
repousser les limites de mes
connaissances
alors ça n'a pas toujours été facile
mais quel bonheur
quel bonheur de comprendre je vous avoue
avoir parfois ressenti la même émotion
qu'en découvrant une toile de maître ou
en lisant un poème
et oui vous savez vous le savez vous
êtes scientifique la pression d'avoir
trouvé cette petite porte qui permet
d'accéder aux coulisses du monde qui
nous entoure et de mieux comprendre
je pense que c'est ce que voulait
exprimer rabelais au xvième siècle quand
il parlait du gai savoir cette
connaissance qui fait du bien
alors comprendre c'est très bien mais
ensuite il faut dire expliqué
transmettre trouver les mots et ça c'est
très certainement le plus difficile
trouver les mots justes sans travestir
la réalité scientifique pour qu en une
minute trente deux minutes le public
totalement profanes comprennent le
phénomène pour que s'engage ce fameux
processus de conceptualisations il faut
trouver les mots les images et maquettes
le rythme et le ton
toutes ces expériences m'ont appris une
chose c'est que tout peut s'expliquer
enfin tout l'état des connaissances à un
instant t et c'est ce que je continue à
faire aujourd'hui à travers deux
émissions comme une envie de jardin une
émission qui comme son nom l indique est
consacré au jardin et à la botanique ça
peut vous surprendre
ne voilà parmi les sujets qui me
tiennent à coeur
il y a
botanic raconter l'histoire des jardins
c'est raconter l'histoire des hommes de
leur déplacement de leur conquête de
leur lien avec la nature et
l'environnement et puis un jardin
finalement c'est le seul endroit où la
science et la poésie se rencontrent
alors la graine a été semé il y à un peu
plus d'un an si vous voulez la voir
pousser et grandit bien c'est le
dimanche à 16h15 sur france 3 et puis il
y a
le monde de jamie le monde ne jamais une
émission de deux heures diffusé en prime
time à 20h50 sur france 3 un double défi
d'abord parce que faire le pari de la
connaissance à une heure de grande
écoute face aux divertissements et aux
séries
c'est pas gagné mais bon on se
débrouille pas mal on se débrouille même
parfois très bien deuxième défi c'est
que je me retrouve maintenant sur le
terrain en compagnie de la journaliste
myriam boulahfa l'objectif étant
d'expliquer les phénomènes au moment
même où ils se déroulent faire ce que
j'appelle de la pédagogie immédiate
alors pour faire cette pédagogie
immédiate j'ai dû franchir un autre type
de limites
je ne m'y attendais pas forcément des
limites physiques comme vont témoigner
les images qui sont diffusées
c'est un extrait de la dernière émission
qui était consacrée aux volcans et aux
séismes il s'agit de l'ascension du
volcan pacaya au guatemala c'est un
volcan qui s'est réveillé il y a un tout
petit peu moins d'un an au mois de
janvier nous mentons en compagnie d'un
géologue emmanuel delstanches qui est
devant et d'un vulcanologues
geoffroy var qui est juste devant moi
moi je suis en fin de peloton en bleu ce
volcan nous intéresse parce qu'il est à
la fois effusif est explosif les deux en
même temps les explosions et des coulées
de lave et c'est ce que nous comptons
bien voir une fois au sommet seulement
voilà l'ascension ne va pas se passer
exactement comme on l'avait imaginé
d'abord il faut imaginer justement que
nous marchons dans une sorte de de
graviers en fait ce sont des esprits des
petits lambeaux de lave refroidie à
chaque pas pendant cette ascension on
s'enfonce jusqu'à la cheville
et puis comme vous pouvez le constater
et bien le volcan se retrouve pris dans
un nuage de brouillard nous sommes sous
les tropiques et pourtant je peux vous
promettre qu'il fait très froid il y à
du vent une condensation comme jamais je
n'en ai vu je vous promets avec des
lunettes c'est un véritable calvaire
écrit cette humidité qui traverse
l'événement les vêtements je le répète
un calvaire au bout de trois heures de
marche depuis le camp de base
nous arrivons enfin au sommet du volcan
au niveau du cratère au niveau de ce
qu'on appelle la lèvre la lèvre du
cratère et là le spectacle est fascinant
vous avez vu quelques images
la lave jaillit à quelques dizaines de
mètres de nous à peu près à l'endroit où
se trouve la régie des lambeaux de lave
qui partent comme ça en hauteur même
faire un peu attention pour bien
vérifier à l'endroit où retombent ccga
l'aide de l'avs
alors on aurait pu s'arrêter là
seulement geoffroy le vulcanologue n'est
pas complètement satisfait parce qu'à
l'endroit où nous sommes nous ne voyons
pas cette fameuse coulée de lave
or nous sommes venus pour voir les deux
c'est ce qui est intéressant sur ce
volcan pour voir la coulée il faut faire
le tour du cratère
est-ce que c'est dangereux on ne sait
pas mais on fait confiance à l'expert et
on décide de le suivre et nous
commençons à contourner le cratère et là
c'est encore pire
c'est pire parce que nous avançons sur
une sorte de dévers qui plonge dans le
cratère et nous marchons dans une sorte
de cendres de l'avs en mentant mieux
comme ça de la sambre cole mêlé à du
soufre ce coup ci on s'enfonce jusqu'à à
mi mollet je vous promets qu'à chaque
page regardait devant ma chaussure
qu'une fissure ne se crée pas au bout
d'une heure on parvient sur l'autre rive
du volcan est là le spectacle est
extraordinaire je ne l'avais jamais vu
il ya d'un côté le cratère avec ses jets
de lave ses lambeaux de lave et de
l'autre une fissure avec la lave qui les
coûts qui s'écoulent les deux en même
temps
alors vous allez me dire pourquoi être
allé jusque là pourquoi avoir franchi
cette limite finalement des images
auraient suffi eh bien je ne le pense
pas je suis même convaincu du contraire
je pense que c'est le seul moyen pour
que le public appréhende mesure la
puissance du phénomène
je crois que le rôle du passeur
c'est aussi un moment donné de créer un
lien physique entre le sujet dont il
parle et le public à qui il s'adresse
et puis les mots mêmes ce qui explique
ne sont jamais aussi juste que lorsque
on les prononce
après avoir ou au moment où l'on ressent
le terrain le terrain vibrer pour rats
comptez un volcan il faut bien sûr avoir
une idée précise de ce qui se passe sous
nos pieds de son mécanisme
mais pour raconter ce qu'il a dans le
ventre et deux fois aussi s'approcher de
la bête
eh bien je crois que d'un côté comme de
l'autre
je ne renoncerai jamais à repousser mes
limites je vous remercie de notre
attention
j'espère vous avoir fait partager un peu
de ce qui me guide
et je vous remercie pour votre fidélité
aussi sans limites car sans vous je ne
serais pas là très bientôt sur les
écrans et sur les réseaux
[Applaudissements]